hey guys welcome back to Westeros weekly
the show that answers your biggest
questions about Game of Thrones I'm
Phillip Melina and here with me this
week is Erik Bosse this is the second of
two preview episodes that we're doing
before the eighth season premiere on
April 14th
it is almost here which is nuts a
reminder that this show is now a podcast
you can get this also Erik's a Game of
Thrones episode breakdowns that you can
be doing throughout the season and our
debrief show all in audio form they come
out earlier on the podcast dreams then
the videos do on YouTube so for instance
if you guys are like the kind that are
gonna be tweeting Erik where's the
effing breakdown just get on your
podcast app and subscribe to the
Westeros weekly podcast specifically you
can do that on Alan iTunes Himalaya
wherever you get your podcast and here's
the truth of it it's really important at
the beginning of a new podcast that we
get a new subscription so if you're
watching this even if you prefer the
video version please go to iTunes and
subscribe to this podcast it helps us
out a lot with doing more of these
yeah just helping new rock stars in
general all right let's start as we
always do the big question
look at those pearly whites
a three-eyed raven upgraded from two
eyes last week
eyes can be white - what did this raven
ask us big question what does the night
King want right no question so every
week we start with the big question this
is the question that we're really gonna
go into this episode later on we're
gonna go into more questions that you
guys sent to us on Twitter with the
hashtag Westeros weekly obviously there
are so many going into this season but
we're gonna start specifically this one
actually came from one of you guys at
bacon awesome love what does the night
King want I this is kind of like the the
big question of what's his real plan
like I've never known his plan cuz he
don't speak
he definitely never talks and he's not
even in the books either so there's
another version of the characters in the
books we'll talk about later but really
this has just been the threat that's
been from the very first scene of the
entire series the White Walkers have
been this looming presence now I guess
you see their booming presence they're
like taking down the wall the night king
has a dragon they're headed south
they're headed for winter
fell they're a full-blown opponent for
all the living characters on the show an
existential threat for everyone who's
currently living and breathing and we
don't know exactly what his agenda is
but we have to assume that it's
something more than just global conquest
or well I mean Junction if it was
something else we could certainly like
be worried that that would be as lame as
that right where it's just like I want
global conquest of a made-up planet you
know like I don't think it's gonna be
that I think something that Game of
Thrones has done really well especially
honestly this show is always bring
things backward to the characters and
that it's actually our characters that
we're already familiar with that are the
most important in the overall events of
Westeros so that's kind of the route
we're gonna take here if you're
wondering what's his greater plan we
think at least it's actually directly
tied to a character on this show that
currently exists and we know the name of
so there's a reason night king is you
know he's this evil ancient force
he's coming south now after thousands of
years right yeah he could have done this
at any point when when they were much
weaker maybe before there were dragons
around right okay which is a big threat
so it makes sense that that for some
reason it's tied to the people who are
alive right now
and also just genuinely that's better
storytelling right it'd be like if
you're watching Halloween and you're
like oh man Mike Myers is such a threat
and then suddenly like a sharknado comes
in and ends a movie for you it'd be like
why do why did that happen unless
instead it's like no this sharknado is
motivated by the character like the
initial shark is who created Michael
Myers at the beginning of the whole
thing right you just want that to tie
backwards yeah some of you could say
well it's purely a seasonal thing the
night Kings just coming south because
this is the first time we've had a long
night level winter but then it's just
like well if it's just natural forces
it's like oh well the shark attacked
Amity Island just because it was summer
like Brian is excited and you order just
did his creeper just cuz it was 28 years
later yes exactly so what's our first
theory of what do we think would be the
most satisfying character that might be
the object or two motivations yeah for
actions
well I think obviously we have to go
directly to the person we've seen them
kind of glare at the
which is Jon Snow so the multiple times
that these guys have faced off I think
it's really interesting that the night
King was like unstoppable and yet he
didn't kill Jon Snow
it feels like multiple times Jon Snow
could have died other than the time he
died but he still could have died and it
feels like maybe this is just a real
Theory mode here night king doesn't want
to kill Jon Snow it could be obviously
there's a bunch of different reasons one
is kind of like maybe he wants to work
with Jon something maybe you want to get
Jon Snow in a certain scenario and then
maybe Jon will can come to a side or
become an heir but I actually think if
you think about the fact that Jon Snow
is kind of on this path that is feels
unfinished right he's been resurrected
before which might be essential to where
the night king watched a place Jon Snow
then this could all make sense as part
of Jon potentially becoming Azure 'hi or
the parents I was promised if John is on
this destined destiny path that has all
these requirements it could be that he
needs to be placed in an exact certain
status where he has accepted what I'm
gonna call the mantle of azor Ahai right
he's not he's not a ready azor Ahai he
needs to you know that prophecy goes
with with killing his baby mama right
like there's a lot of very specific
things that need to happen that might
need to be exactly who John becomes and
then the night king can either try to
turn him or kill him or something but
it's all about Jon actually has to
achieve that status first that's
interesting and maybe we could be
looking at a scenario where the night
king because he seems to be a green seer
one of the people in the Game of Thrones
universe who can see into the future and
see events before they happen
as Jojen Reed and bran is is it possible
of the night King knows that his death
is imminent and is looking for this heir
to replace him to lead the White Walkers
and that's the way that John could
vanquish the forces of the night king by
becoming a new leader and taking them
back north there's this idea that John
could follow in the same steps of cold
hands in the books but they merge the
character with Benjen stark in the show
and the way Benjen stark had that kind
of half white appearance you know
mulatto yeah different the phonetic
professorship white he said that he
would have stabbed in the
with dragonglass when he was about to
die and that allowed him to stay in this
weirdly pseudo immortal state and some
people are thinking that that could be
John's fate and the way that he has been
brought back to life before and the way
that the night king was created by the
church on the force by being stabbed in
the in the heart with the dragonglass
blade that that could be John's fate and
he could fill in to become the new night
king or the night's king which we'll
talk about more in this episode and
become the new leader of the White
Walkers and well and kind of moving on
toward our next person that I think this
could be about it but it still connects
here let's remember I the reason I was
saying that maybe azor Ahai is a mantle
that you can earn or achieve is because
maybe no one currently has it the night
king is down to to wait until john has
it but he doesn't kill John early
because John wanna had become as aura
high yet and then maybe somebody else
can become as aura high so he's waiting
for someone to become officially as or
high and then he can kill them
but for example let's say John does go
down well the azure Ahai prophecy is is
very 2019 it's gender-neutral that's
true right it could be anyone so yeah
that's what they said it was prince or
princess as a teacher exactly yeah yeah
so it could be Daenerys
yes Daenerys could actually be the
princess that was promised she has a lot
of things that line up with the prophecy
as well so kind of same idea but maybe
his whole motivation is waiting til she
ends up as Ora high and then taking her
down because she's the only one that
could potentially stop him right and she
does have dragons and some are saying
like he didn't really know dragons
existed in their full form this way with
the three that she had until more recent
seasons of the show but again if we
assume that he's a green seer that he
can see things that are happening all
over Westeros and Essos then maybe he
knew that these dragons existed there's
also the the long-running debate over
what is the true sources magic in this
show is it the return of the White
Walkers that are reactivating formerly
dead magic or is it the return of the
dragon eggs is it like the egg or the
King which came first right and I
thinking King
but the dragon eggs I feel like are this
kind of sleeping magic that came from
esos somewhere deep in the shadow lands
and the night king possibly saw these
dragon eggs there is a looming presence
because of course dragons existed
throughout the Targaryen dynasty for
years and years but they were dying out
they were becoming weaker and weaker
over general maybe dog sized right yeah
and then they they were sickly and they
would die you know but in this case
maybe he's like oh this is going to
reimburse a major threat to my power and
I have to destroy or consume this super
power and he's already done it with one
of the Dragons and maybe his right I do
it with the other two Daenerys dragons
are similar at least to balerion and
these ancient dragons that are known to
be these huge threats so it is kind of
you know there's been a reawakening in
the dragon force yes so he could
potentially have suddenly cared because
this is legit magic that's going on and
maybe he wants to wield all of the magic
he clearly has his own kind of eyespace
magic which could mean why also I'm just
gonna remind everyone the wall was
supposedly protected by a magical
barrier as well as just being real cold
um so and very tall and yeah yeah
exactly a new ball ish so it might not
have just been fire that was needed to
take him down but specifically a kind of
magical fire that was being wielded by
the night king that kind of could be one
kind of microcosm of his overall plan of
I need to wield all the the magic under
my power in order to achieve my plan so
maybe he actually needed there he needed
to wait until there were dragons of a
certain status around again so he could
wield him so he could cross the wall and
then his ultimate plan there if we just
assume that dragons are a tool to get to
his greater plan his plan if we assume
it's Daenerys would just be to take out
the person who could potentially be a
check on that power as someone children
right - it's like like hey I need your
son to do this crazy thing it's kind no
these are my kids like like no thank you
so he has to kill her obviously I would
take them yeah well there's another
potential source of magic that could be
that his main target bran right Brandon
Stark our young
yeah so so obviously these two are
linked pretty intensely right and I
think if you kind of remember go back to
season six is when they have their their
interactions and the night King suddenly
and violently gropes right and they
catch his brand off guard but Lee it
leaves a mark that brand will show you
on a doll if you need the those there
was clearly some sort of transference in
that moment could be some sort of power
transference honestly okay so you know
there is the fact that bran is the the
three-eyed Raven at this point the
three-eyed Raven comes with its own
magical abilities tied to the children
of the forest yes so again it kind of
goes with that same theory of if the
knight King already has his own magic
that he's wielding but he kind of wants
to be the one vessel of all magic you
know then he's maybe after bran who is
the current wielder of the most strong
opposing force of magic and also the
magic that probably made him yes yeah
and that's a good point because the
children of the force we saw in season
six in this flashback the children of
the forest created the White Walkers
that was a big reveal that they created
them as it's like White's weapon of mass
destruction right in their war with the
first men back in ancient times and it
ended up being this kind of thing that
blew up in their faces
maybe because they found out White
Walkers have this way of reproducing and
growing their numbers out of their own
control and became a threat that in the
way that you could argue nuclear power
has become a threat to our own existence
and blows up in our fans loads up in our
face so we might be seeing a scenario
where the knight King feels some kind of
anger at his own existence and is going
after the children of the forest and
maybe the three-eyed Raven is the human
link that he has with the children in
the forest and bran as a new three-eyed
Raven is his new target because he wants
to get back at them and also he's the
biggest threat right he has the actual
real power that he has of sights a green
scene and yeah connections with the
natural world and the power of the old
gods
I like how like I picked this all sounds
and like based on like prophecy and
destiny and whatnot but that you kind of
also implied that like it's rooted in
like self hatred it was just like he
looks at his reflection and like froze
stupid you're stupid spiky those frosted
tips
yeah but we should we should acknowledge
the fact that this is going deep deep
deep in the theory in the books seem to
love to go into this backstory cuz they
are books and that's the point of books
we're talking about a show and they have
like hinted at some of this like deeper
mythology it will be very interesting to
see if the show interesting is my word
to use for surprising or potentially
polarizing with a lot of people watch
even through if the show decides to go
this deep in a theory for these final
six episodes in order to provide some
answers and payoff for people have these
questions but it is a potential way that
they could go and we have a deeper
possible theory for the direction than I
can could be going in regards to the
children of the forest if that is his
main MO right yeah isn't there also that
theory with bran where like I mean I
know it's really out there but that idea
that bran maybe like Ward backward into
the the first man who was turned into
the night king yes we're animals night
king exactly the brand equals night King
theory were essentially like he he is
fighting himself all these years later
and you know it's kind of like now the
night King has to go back and stop the
old version himself from stopping the
new versions like that kind of
complicated yes back to the future to
right of like time travel right well
watch it like it's almost like that
movie predestination you see the Ethan
Hawke movie where that whole complicated
the idea that thought experiment and if
this sounds crazy do we have made a
video about I think we made a video
about this right after season 7 ended
this is something that established by
the show like a history as we knew it
had already been affected by time travel
that happened later in the series
Hodor the reason Hodor says Hodor over
and over again is that his mind was
essentially fried from a time that would
later happen in the future where bran
went back in time to when he was a boy
it's the door like logic or whatever the
slaughterhouse-five kind of energy but
what if the being unstuck in time
usually means essentially time travel
through through consciousness but it
often doesn't really change anything
then there's kind of the
quantum leap version of being on second
time where you hop around and you make
these small impacts and then there's
kind of what's almost more realistic of
Game of Thrones it's like oh you enter
someone else's brain where there already
is a consciousness and you fry their
brain right doing that and there's
there's evidence of this that you can
get trapped in someone's body back in
time like in the sunken place
essentially the old three-eyed Raven
told bran
you can get trapped underneath the waves
Jojen Reed warned him about this you
can't warg for too long because you'll
get trapped there you could get trapped
inside that body like tobias and the
Animorphs he became an athlete yeah get
trapped in the body of a hawk I'm gonna
work at hand worse records as much as I
can but the there's also this people tie
this theory to lots of historical events
in Westeros people believe that the Mad
King may have gone mad because it was
brand telling him in the past to burn
them all burned being the White Walkers
but then the mad Kings just started to
lose its mind away Hodor you could say
did and just decided to apply that to
wildfire and all of his political
enemies right it's interesting this idea
of bran has a megaphone that's kind of
too loud for us to process it reminds me
of is it in dogma maybe where the voice
of God is too overwhelming for people to
hear it
how so they their heads explode when
they see their heads explode yeah but
that's what he's doing just like he's
she cuz it's kind of silly also if
brands like hey maybe we should burn
them all and it's like hundred hundred
years earlier or something like a guy
goes nuts and kills a bunch of people
because he like bran just said that one
and wouldn't that be ironic if the old
gods as the people of Westeros know them
are actually people from the future
speaking to them from the future I mean
isn't that what being a God is in modern
time is like aliens helping yes just not
understanding it's like somebody came in
and said some amazing work it in
McConaughey from interstellar or not uh
he'll work in a McConaughey reference
every time you do an Animorph reference
but let's talk about maybe more broadly
the night king could be aimed at the
entire stark family so what's my idea
with that so the Starks are one of these
families that can be traced all the way
back to the 1950s or even before that
and there were some of the like the
first men and there is this clearly
we've already seen the idea that the
night King comes from the first men most
likely
it also could potentially be a start
straight up could be a strike right
there's that quote of old man's where
she she's not talking about this version
of the night King she's talking about
the night's king yeah apostrophe s
yeah which which is it could be the same
character we actually don't really know
because the show doesn't mention that
one in the book doesn't mention the
making so say it is the same one though
even old man who is the definitive like
anything she says it's true person she's
saying you know people think he could be
a Bolton he could be an umber a Flint
but then she settles on know he was a
stark yeah the night's king was a guy he
was a Lord Commander of the Nights Watch
and he decided he fell in love with
either a white or a white Walker it's
not really clear but he's one of these
guys who'd betrayed the the Brothers of
the Nights Watch and became this
mysterious mist about figure but the
idea is this guy was a stark so if the
show might tether that link together and
decide that the night king as we've seen
on the show is actually this guy he's an
ancient stark and might have some kind
of lingering grudge against the
surviving current generation of the
stark family
yeah which especially makes sense if you
stick with that logic we were saying at
the beginning of like just keep the
characters we already know and and so
this idea of is the night's king the
same as the night king it's like it
would kind of suck if they now brought
out of characters like okay it's gonna
be hard to keep track of but this guy
he's called Knights King right and
they're gonna and they're gonna be very
like commonly confused like I don't
think they're gonna do that yeah and in
the showrunners of the show Benioff and
Weiss are studied academics when it
comes to the books like they're the ones
who got this show because they correctly
guessed who Joe's real mother was when
they pitched it
the idea of George RR Martin's so the
idea of that they had never heard of the
night's king or might have misread it
and created a new character called the
night king there's going to be some
greater influence I believe from the
night king as we see him on the show
from the character in the books there's
I wouldn't be surprised if there is some
kind of backstory to him right I
connected to the Starks well and
speaking of of his potential backstory
there's a few things we know from the
show so let's say we do take some stuff
from from the books and we do connect
back to the stuff we were time with bran
earlier you know being connected to the
the children of the forest I'm kind of
thinking that you know we're talking
about the night king
a greater motivation one element that
you know was so great we had these
character motivations one thing I'm
wondering is like where's he headed
right I don't think it's like a
beachfront condo and Dorne
like I think he actually has a very
specific place he's trying to get to on
the other side of the wall I'm curious
if maybe part of his plan is all about
getting to the Isle of faces all right
yeah right so if you guys don't remember
that's in the southern river lands
basically and it could be where the
children of the forest have run off
because they were cast off and almost
all killed right if there are any
children of forest left it could be
where these there's like a bunch of
weirwood trees there it's kind of like
their networking closet you know we're
like all the way wood trees I mean you
have to reset the weirwood trees when it
goes down but it's also where the
children of the forest and the first men
signed that initial treaty yes and it
also could be where the night king was
created so if there's any kind of sacred
magical Native American burial ground
where everything goes back to it could
be yeah we think that because I think it
was some old breakdowns that we did
where we saw that spiral symbol that the
children forest used and the night King
and the White Walkers have
reappropriation it and we found out that
it's because the White Walkers were
birthed from the children of the forest
and that's why they reused their symbols
that shot that place where the night
king was created we don't know exactly
where that was we don't know if those
north of the wall we don't know if it
was somewhere south of the wall and one
theory is that that could be on the Isle
of faces where it was kind of the
capital of the children for us it's the
last place where they ended up settling
and to this day we don't know much about
it other than like a some cult of green
men I believe is what they're called go
out to dots they they they're only ones
who a little on that Isle and they keep
up the weirwood trees and they basically
I guess they're the guys who like like
the torches under orchard tree stick to
keep it they they keep it well-kept
they're a groundskeeper willies and that
could be where the night king is headed
because that could be the last known
location on the children of the forest
and that might be his true objective in
order to eliminate this threat of these
a little horrible and he brought him
into the world that I mean that would be
interesting it might be a little random
for people who are watching the show
without as dedicated of an understand
the books sure but at the same time it's
kind of like hey whatever happened to
the Keebler's like you know I mean like
if you were watching the show it is one
of the things that you know we obviously
as we go through this this season we're
gonna be like wondering hey is are they
gonna pay this opportunity pay that all
one of the thing is kind of like how
about that whole involvement of the
children of the forest all the magic
here or is it gonna I don't think it's
gonna stay so political yeah i snotted
go into this I have some mix but I feel
like if it doesn't stay so political it
doesn't go to much in the myth I think
and then we're just talking about the
main objective of the characters and
their whole story arc with John and
Daenerys and what their destiny is yeah
and who they're who they're gonna end up
with which Jorah Mormont and hoping just
finds his way back in there and that
actually could be the main objective of
the night king is this connection
between Jon and Daenerys right yeah he's
trying to join their friends own yes
yeah waiting for a spot with Dany is it
I mean Barristan Selmy is he's gone
there's room you can't have too many
suitors yeah speaking from experience
Derek well my experience it could ever
have enough yeah so the so but the point
you trying to make about if the night
king is motivated by not just John and
not just Danny but maybe their Union
then you're talking baby yes the baby
that it will probably exist right I mean
those eyes that they gave each other
during the boat sex is a pregnancy test
it is see here certainly you know right
away when it happens I've been told
right well there's only one purpose that
I've been instructed it's to procreate
yeah I'm really terrible sex education
growing up deaf words it does feel like
in like narrative stories like this or
whatever like you know any active sex
kind of results in a kid and that kid is
like destined for some amazing story
yes unlike very much real life oh yeah
the night king has a history of one teen
male babies he got them from crap oh
right he does though yes he does he
kidnaps him he converts them into that's
like his main way of procreation because
it doesn't seem like the the White
Walkers can procreate the traditional
way in the same way there's a chance
that that one who has the big staff and
the horse sort of that could be a
ey Walker we don't know it's got nice
hair yeah we don't ya but as far as we
know we haven't seen any white walkers
who are women right as far as we know
yes
and we don't know if this is a matter of
like keeping their because it seems like
they live forever once they're created I
mean the night King is thousands and
thousands of years old himself so I
think as long as they don't accidentally
trip and fall into some dragonglass
right they're gonna be fine but I think
he just wants to grow his numbers not
just like create an army of undead
whites but but what if I give you a
stronger push of maybe there's a reason
like why he needs to grow his numbers
and it's not just the fact that I just
want a literal bigger army maybe there
it's essential that so say we were
saying these or high theories earlier
you know maybe Danny's is RI maybe
Johnston's were high really great
argument for their baby to be azor Ahai
right and you know I don't know that the
night Keane can do his little press-on
fingernail touch to your forehead to
Pete to adults but he certainly can do
him to babies so if that's his aura high
the person that's destined to kill them
kill him and he knows that that's the
truth then he's going back to the baby
version he's Terminator in John Connor
yeah like the t800 they sent back to
baby John Connor or Linda Hamilton won't
you just office offset but just the idea
of like taking out this threat when you
know it's the Hitler theory yeah if you
could go back in time you gotta kill a
baby Hitler it's it's part of it what's
really interesting on that is what if
this baby is like baby Hitler and like
night king is like look you guys don't
know this gets so much worse Wow night
King did nothing wrong night King yes
the protagonist hero of this story and
it's really us who are them yeah I
really like you guys taking that quote
of Eric saying the night King did
nothing wrong just like just making you
pay for that oh boy yeah that is an
interesting take right like a lot of
people are saying this baby between John
and Danny is if not I was aura higher
the Princeton was promises at least the
Song of Ice and Fire
you know literalized on the show some of
you are saying John is already that's
Song of Ice and Fire so why does this
baby need to also be the Song of Ice and
Fire but we just don't know the
circumstances or even if this baby
exists but we don't know what the
circumstance will be very interesting to
see how that baby is born if he does or
she does come to pass and what
significance they will have on the
show there's also a servant minder that
you know stark blood does have magic to
it I you know that's why most likely
brain is able to warg why they're able
to have this special connection with the
direwolves where they essentially are
the are all wargs Targaryen blood
famously also has that that connection
to dragons so the it's not insignificant
it's not a you know Gillies baby yeah
baby yeah yes it's a pretty significant
baby if that baby doesn't have what I
love what we don't even know that it's
his baby exists but it's got to because
they had sex once right yes but if it if
it exists it has to be super important
yes I think it must be and if it's not
like the fusion of two magical
bloodlines it could just be the
perception of the fusion of those that
is enough of a threat for the knight
King to want to take it out or bring it
into his own clan in his own race I like
the idea of them the imager you're just
doing with your hands is like the night
king will deliver the baby and he's like
you got I mean could be compared to
Voldemort right Voldemort's thought that
Harry Potter was the the greatest threat
and the prophecy
so his thinking that Harry Potter was
the threat ended up fulfilling his own
prophecy and making Harry Potter the
threat it could have been
what's-his-face Longbottom for all we
knew no unless it was a puberty powers
of puberty I don't think it would we
just need a JK Rowling to rewrite can
and again to make everyone's gay
now everyone's gay and they make their
poop disappear oh boy if you're keeping
up with that that's great all right so
uh moving on we are gonna get to more of
your guys's questions oh my god the
Ravens just collided into a cage okay
we're gonna get to more of your
questions in a second and we're gonna do
some rapid fire ones but new segment
that we're gonna bring up the death pool
yeah so Eric and I each thank you a
filled out a death pool well we started
our ideas on our bracket for our death
pool but we're gonna talk through a
little bit of our thinking here but you
guys can actually play along with us on
guest the throne calm so we're gonna
pick who we think are gonna live or die
during the final season of the show but
there is still time for you guys to join
just search for the Westeros weekly pool
on guest
drone comm and then you just in turn you
can compare it what will see your
predictions compared to ours compared to
everybody else that enters and obviously
what we're gonna give shoutouts to the
people that are performing the best and
we're gonna give a prize to the ultimate
winner and it could be Eric's job yes
it's yeah yeah this if you can have a
great guest gets the throne pool and if
it's better than mine you know what you
deserve to have this job you deserve to
have a job in that we'll never deal with
Game of Thrones again the show will be
done but if you can if you can beat me
on that then so alright so you guys go
there and you kind of consider these
names as we're gonna go through and
consider some of them right now but
we're just gonna kind of like let you
know our thinking on circuit stuff we
don't were not gonna have the same
bracket by them no just don't know you
know I don't want us to have the same
breath all right it doesn't work out all
right Jon Snow so live or die I think I
think Jon Snow is I think we're a guess
on Jon Snow and only because I think the
show will want to make a statement about
jon snow's behavior and reward him with
the opportunity to write he's he's
adjusted and changed and he had he's a
character that literally had an oath to
death right and then he still changed
away from that oath and did the most
amazing thing of sleeping with the
wildly yes
buddy buddy you showed that he was
willing to bend right and bend the knee
so oh yeah I'm down also I think I think
Jon's gonna make it also cuz like you
know in don't kill the dude twice yeah
Danny I think Danny is a goner and I
think the telltale moment for me is in
season seven when she had an opportunity
to show that she was a wiser more apt
and more able deserving ruler and she
she executed the tarly's just to make a
flyer and and granted the tarly's a lot
of you guys point on the comments they
had an opportunity to bend the knee and
they still did it but she they kind of
forced her to that position where she
had to execute them to make a point most
like cooking isn't like the only form of
execution right she still had to bend
toward her flair for the dramatic yeah I
think Ned Stark executed somebody in the
pilot and we think he's the most noble
guy out there right it's not the
execution it's the fact that she kind of
tortured them I think her death will be
something that will be used to motivate
Jon into whatever hit the next final
phase and are
the potential prophecy killing miss her
if John is the principal was promised
all right this is a fan fave so you
could see it go another way Tyrion yes
I'm gonna say Tyrion survives and not
only that he becomes the most likely of
the people we've seen to become ruler of
whatever is left over of Westeros
interest and most deserving i think
george RR martin has obviously if you
read the books Tyrians the best
character to read his chapters he's a
character you're most excited for has
the best line seem to be the wisest
character on the show and i think it
would be a shame to if George are
Martin's just like you know what no it's
not his story after all and he doesn't
deserve well that kind of like is a slap
in the face to the people that think
that it's samwell tarly story cuz a lot
of people do a lot a lot of people do
think that it's like you know this is
all a story that that Sam is telling in
the future right and he's recording the
story there's a Song of Ice and Fire
and it's all he's you know the
equivalent george RR martin i just like
that you're kind of like or we just make
it tyrion is I don't think we're
mutually exclusive I think they both can
like the Sam is the guy who writes down
this Song of Ice and Fire and Tyrion is
his historical source who we yeah and
there's so Tyrians a ruler sam like
shaves his head and like starts speaking
softly becomes the varus all right I
think I'm good on Tyrion surviving me
too I think so too
Aria okay so I think that she is either
going to well the bracket doesn't allow
for this but either going to disappear
into the east
sorry into the west to see what's west
of Westeros she's essentially gonna be
the Christopher Columbus or something or
the Magellan or something of that world
or she dies yes and she dies because she
sticks too closely to needing to
continue crossing off names on her list
I think I think it's a good way to think
of it some people are saying like what
kind of stories Game of Thrones gonna be
is it gonna be like Lord of the Rings
which ended up famously with Frodo
sailing off into the sunset now we're
gonna get that kind of ending for aria
or is it this new darker tale that
george RR martin and he has said that
while Lord of the Rings is probably his
biggest literary and
luhan's on the show and he he loves
Tolkien he has made some deliberate
moves to not make it this kind of
tolkien-esque allegory for the triumph
of the human spirit now he wants to show
the depths of human treachery so is he
gonna lean more into that kind of early
in the books and early in the series
spirit of the show and allow for
characters to selfishly go after their
ambitions even to their own bitter ends
and for me I think that's the direction
Ari is gonna go even though George or
Martin has said the past two days like I
always pictured Arya being there at the
end of the show or at the end of the
books I always thought Aria would be the
one to survive George doesn't have to go
in the exact direction that George Mr in
head for the end and even Georgia Marine
has said that the ending of his books
will be very different from the show
anyway so I think the show will decide
to end arias Tale by having her go on
some kind of kamikaze suicide mission
yeah assassination mission and a Walter
bliss complete but then maybe has to
write re at the top of the list and her
final move and cross it out yeah it
allows herself to expire so I like that
because it also is you know we do a lot
of there's a lot of movies out there
about world war two and it's kind of
like every everyone so honorable and you
know maybe that's that's true it was the
the greatest generation people referred
it that way
but that's not the story that we've come
to know here right it's people that are
like yeah maybe I'll fight in your war
even though it's like clearly the
biggest threat of all time like Cersei
is kind of like maybe not right our
characters have selfish motivations and
I think it'd be weird if they all were
like alright now we all need to join
forces and and humans versus white like
that I don't that's not the show that
easy or well that's not the story that
george RR martin is telling yeah okay
alright so she did i play to you dad is
that what you're gonna presume dead so
currently Philip and I have exact same
at bracket all right Cersei dead
she got a die well I will divert to you
just for the sake of this I'm gonna say
sir su survives even though all my
instincts are telling me that the show's
gonna kill her off I think if I'm
assuming that Ari is gonna die I think
Cersei might survive just go together
maybe yeah that's probably a better way
saying I want to write live then so you
do live I'll do die yeah I could see
that thing we're like maybe she like
somehow does her
but then she has to like like hide her
true identity because everyone hates her
now and she has to like be a commoner
now and like clean poop um cool
Sansa this is a hard one for me yeah
this is tough because I don't see a
version of this show but it just seems
like the trajectory of the show in
recent seasons has been to be like oh no
no Sophie Turner's is a new star of the
show get behind her she's a able ruler
and I never would have the x-men
franchise as well yeah I don't the game
of thrones that I know in love doesn't
have Sansa as like a surviving hero at
the end of it but it seems like the game
of Thrones that has been the case in
season 6 and season 7 will allow sanso
to survive yeah I think she'll live on
that's I'll put live because I think
that she'll be left with Winterfell and
she'll have to keep ruling over
Winterfell there's not really anybody
else that's a good person for that and
Jon doesn't even Billie seem to want to
so if anything maybe Jon gets the Iron
Throne but she's still the warden of the
north yeah reward debt award award Lady
of there's a different name for it I
don't know what it is so I'll put Liv
yeah I'll put live as well alright so
we're just gonna fly through some of
these but we're not gonna commit to
these answers but let's just go real
fast I'll say ok so brand live or die
I'm gonna say die I'm gonna say live
alright Varys Varys died he was promised
to die gia Lannister ooh Jaime if it's
Ark is complete of Redemption
- yes they died yeah
just please put that right we've
described his arc as that of Hamlet
avenging his father whose brother stole
the throne from Hanano Hamlet didn't
suffer this much yeah yeah so die
you're a great joy die I think she'll go
down and battle probably protecting
Theon I'm gonna say live I think you're
right I think Theon and your onigen
cancel each other out and Yara will go
on to become the rightful ruler of the
iron oh that's not a bad one yeah yeah
so you're on I'm gonna say I don't think
he's gonna survive I think he's gonna
have the sickest death in season eight I
think you're on stethoscope the Ramsay
Bolton death of this season Oh
interesting kind of he's kind of earned
it a little bit yeah
so yeah I'll put it die as well Samwell
Tarly I think we'll live yes I think he
has to be the one to tell the story yeah
let's see if there's a so many names on
this list I think we should just jump
around a little bit to grey worm
I think grey worms gonna die I think
he's gonna die in the Battle of
Winterfell we're all gonna cry me too I
think my Sande either could also go down
like at the same time you know a little
Romeo and Juliet II or something or I
don't
and then who else is interesting here mo
Sondra I I think Melisandre cuz it was a
moment Barris where she said I will we
will see each other again no she said
that Arya and I think Arya might be the
one to kill me yeah that's a good point
and then of the names left uh of course
again you guys can be filling out your
own bracket on gesta throne calm look up
the Westeros weekly pull on there but
the last one I want to mention is I mean
is the night King still alive at the end
of this thing oh yeah see I'm going to
it was he ever alive right right he's
always been but as the lived lowlife
that he currently has I think will not
be around at the end of the show I don't
think I think die yeah okay cool all
right so you guys should be filling out
your bracket - and we again we're gonna
give a shout out to whoever's doing the
best on there and we're gonna give
Eric's job to the worst
but back to your Twitter Q&A questions
ibises oh god
the effects are so real look at the
three eyes on this thing this is a very
specific Simpson desk
version of a three-eyed Raven yeah cool
so what's a Twitter question this is a
lightning round of Twitter question the
other way you guys have sent it to us
with the hashtag Westeros weekly on
Twitter you can keep doing that here we
go Eric fire this is from let's see
Darryl young busy business okay is
Tyrion a Targaryen ooh good question all
right so turians mother is a Joanna
Lannister race and we know that she got
like friendly with the Mad King Aerys
Targaryen like my real friendly so there
is rumors that they could have had an
affair and then on top of that there's
the fact that Tywin Lannister was not
just so mean to him but was always like
you're no son of mine I meant that
literally and it would kind of be a nice
parallel to Catelyn Stark's energy with
Jon Snow oh yeah where it's this like
look I'll raise you I'll feed you but
I'm very aware that you're some other
dudes baby right yeah there's another
woman I mean in Tyrion of course led to
her dying in childbirth so there's
really no way to know the truth and now
Tywin is dead as well so we don't really
know who how he's connected but some
people are saying that Tyrion could be
the third Dragon Rider they said the
dragon has three heads and that
prophesied vision but now there's not
three dragons so it's like right it's
neat also maybe one secret reveal of a
major character being a secret Targaryen
the whole time might be already one too
many unless it's kind of like the Cylons
of Battlestar yes
I was gonna say Battlefield Earth yeah a
very different property all right but
but I don't know just cuz that Tyrion
the Targaryen is like a stupid funny
thing to say to get the literation of
that they might do it like they did
drogon the Dragons they was dragged on
yeah but it was a typo and so yeah stick
with it yeah not everyone can be a
Targaryen oh okay okay all right let's
see careful flying and this thing
probably already had two eyes the third
eye has to match the other side like how
good the Ravens are at hovering flapping
like a drone all right this one's from
at Brian McDaniel ash
no sorry my McDaniel asks does Daario
naharis show up in season 8 that's one
of these loose thread characters kind of
like how Gendry was and then showed up
again so will that have a for Dario well
we know that Dario went off to join the
second son's a team or an army of
mercenaries and esos when he left Danny
and he was left in charge of marine or
he came from the second son's and then
he used his buddies and all the combined
forces to take charge of marine and the
golden company is now another cell sword
army from Essos ed is making their way
to Westeros to join the army of Cersei
and help defend King's Landing and
whoever defeat whatever is left over so
maybe he could show up with the golden
company
Miley Mints against an evil would yeah
that's what's kind of crazy about it I
think we're done with that character
yeah I think we're done with that actor
they'll show up if he shows up it'll be
a third act I mean this is where you get
McConaughey another sales soared and now
it's profit promise you get an animal
understand there's still a soul inside
you that's showin didn't they ran the
visser ship yeah it wasn't a show at
that point two seasons than done hey
let's reboot an amorous well it's such a
great prop guys are here for animorphs
breakdown all right this is from ma e
Fletch once the will we hear the night
king talk I don't know I don't know it's
like good that if the Jaws jaws shark
was name was Josh but it's like if he
talked right if he was like such a great
threat you just kind of constantly see
him and he's like I'm gonna eat you and
you're like what okay no we don't need
that yeah I kind of wanted to talk at
one point have a real silly sounding
voice yeah Danny DeVito but a really
solid rap okay dance oh man this is a
busy Raven get it
Twitter Birds all right this one's from
at Dylan F McKinnon ass ooh I kind of
almost forgot about this at this point
who wins cleganebowl all right yeah
clicking bow the race to the bottom of
the bowl like the mountain
in hound but know this so this is just
kind of the idea that these two need to
fight each other they're brothers
they're they're tall we saw them
fighting in the tourney of the hand and
the very yeah I was the handsome
different so next back yeah different
actor playing him
but they fought to defend so Loras
Tyrell and the Hound just kind of pissed
off because he lost his house and start
of the battle because they had to go in
there and and the king called it to a
stop but they made a promise he's like
all fight you again someday brother I
can't see me and then he jumped out of
the ring and then WrestleMania has got
to be coming back at simple right and if
it's gonna be the character arcs that
we're kind of always all hoping for then
it's the Hound will win that but also
it's this show and the mountain is
already like a reanimated corpse yes so
I don't know it could be like like a
really sad but truth but he might the
mountain might win it yeah yeah III
think in this case it'd be best if they
took each other out again yeah I want
all battles to be kind of like with
Brienne in the Hound where they was kind
of a standstill a draw yeah a draw where
the hounds head gets crushed yeah ah
let's see alright if you guys are
hearing those kakao sound effects by the
way we put a lot of money to get those
recordings oh yeah let's see this is
from at monka s 247 ask does jaqen
H'ghar show up ooh
jaqen H'ghar so the faceless man who
gave aria coin that that she's already
used up yes so she he doesn't have that
reason to show up anymore
but does he show up in the events of
Westeros he's in Braavos the last we saw
mm-hmm and dead kind of the last we saw
right he was such a confusing guy yeah
I'm actually alive no you've actually
killed someone else you've he's never
gonna give you a straight answer this
one this is were the mystery of like why
was he in captivity in the first place
when Arya first met him in season 2 if
he's supposed to be this badass and
ninjas she wanted to be unless he wanted
to be so we don't really know what this
guy's story is but I think Game of
Thrones is told as much of a story as
they're going to tell in the show would
be my guess I kind of hope we see him
one more time but it's a little bit like
the fanboy part of me not right
I think they'd it's not as much of a
lingering loose threat as new mario was
when we were asking where did that dire
wolf go like we've had we spent a lot of
time with him ya know sick reveal like
right at the end you know the night king
is about to kill john and instead at
hands john his hand and helps him up and
then takes off his face and it's been
shocking her guard the whole time and
they become buds oh man yeah that's
that's how it should it that's you have
that pain alright this is from at
turtles tweets ask will Arya finish her
list what do you think I think yes I
think that is the list when when the
bride in Kill Bill starts a list you're
setting up your structure for your
characters journey and you got to get
back yes check odds list yes yeah so I
think yeah I think she'll at least get
far enough down to it where we'll be
down to one or something and then like
we said like you know the list might
cost her her own life right it could be
like a big moral decision that she gets
to at the end where she has to decide is
finishing her list worth it she's down
to one last list is killing Cersei or
killing Melisandre whoever else is on it
and maybe that's the way her character
grows beyond these past conflicts and
turns into someone new what's tough is
that you also she kind of has already
done things like that right like she
left the Hound alive but he technically
was on her list she'll probably
reencounter beric Dondarrion her
lissandra I mean so maybe it won't be
the exact version of the list that we
were most familiar with but she has some
depth to pay yes the list is gonna come
back for sure yeah I also like the idea
that the dead people who oh sorry once I
graven is that a quick point to make the
Ravens are hovering above us just I just
think it's funny that if she does get
through all the list and then the night
king just reanimates everyone from the
list god damn it
yeah so to start all over again ruled
the list alright graven bring it in yeah
dirty Raven alright good
damn dirty Ravens at I am Sandeep SD
asks who will be the Shireen style
oh no the Edward Sheeran's IO cameo this
season well we could do both we get
serene edge
Aaron's character let have the same end
okay so ed Sheeran is was there because
the actress who plays Aria is just a big
fan of his music so is it just like
another British rock star is gonna be
the the cameo this season
Oh like Conan Suns your something
British I don't even know yeah I don't
know yeah I I kind of hope they don't
like a lot of late in this series shows
do this like lost worked in some random
cameos in the finals they got robbed
McIlhenny to play one of them island
people I just remember that uh Sophie
Turner's and she liked gonna marry Joe
Jonas oh yeah so that's my call Joe
Jonas is gonna show up as like a third
start looking Baratheon looking like
black haired type guy wait what does Joe
Jonas play like a post puberty Rob Aaron
at the end like I feel like a huge dick
and very sickly attractive basically yes
and then what do we got guys Kraven
here's another question from I've let it
go like attacked me at snatch snack
Huddleston asked who's Brienne gonna
hook up with Jaime or torment
oh I mean why you gotta be one why not
both yeah I think Jamie's probably the
destined way but man I hope tormund gets
a piece of the action
yeah I mean it feels like the kind of
thing where it's like if it were a
different show it'd be that thing like
he's like torment like you don't want to
die a virgin do you I mean yeah I don't
know should hook up with anybody right
it says shipping too hard let's just let
her have her own journey where she
doesn't have to settle down yeah I mean
she might not be into him and she might
have like respect I don't know yeah all
right connection with Jamie yeah that
may need to be all if there's any person
that it just would be perfect for it
she's already there it's Podrick he's
the only man that could wield that yeah
that's true yeah alright guys thanks so
much for watching and listening was to
Westeros weekly uh thanks for
subscribing
this right here the new rock star
channel but also again very important if
you subscribe to us on iTunes to the
podcast version the Westeros weekly
podcast stream it's not just this show
it's all of our Game of Thrones coverage
it's our theories it's our Eric's
breakdowns that are incoming and again
it comes out earlier on the podcast and
it does on the YouTube channel and by
like a significant amount so please
please please subscribe to that it also
helps us a lot if we can rank it
actually is pretty important for us to
support the show if we if you ever see
us in iTunes podcast if you go to like
all charts and then go to TV and film
it's like a very small group and then go
like hosted by guys named Eric and fill
up as long as we rank high in that it
helps us a lot to support this show so
help us rank and share it with your
friends because new subscribers is how
it ranks
yes follow us on twitter at new rock
stars tweet those questions to us you'll
be in the show like this was and it'll
be brought by raven so it'll stop at
your house get your question you submit
via twitter too at what our hashtag
Westeros weekly on those that's how we
find them how the Raven finds them
specifically follow me at fimo you can
add Phillip Malina yes yeah oh you have
to that's my Instagram and my job yes
and you can follow me on twitter and
instagram @ e a vos thank you guys for
joining us thank you so much I'm so
excited to see you next week
and wet myself
[Music]